alain webster et professeur en économie
de l'environnement à l'école de gestion
de l'université de sherbrooke bonsoir
alain webster bons joueurs que les
d'abord le contexte de cette poursuite
du président de l'administration trame
contre la californie plusieurs
stratégies de cette administration
clairement climato-sceptiques visant à
démanteler un ensemble de stratégies
permettant la lutte aux changements
climatiques donc ce qu'on peut reprocher
l'administration 3 ne s'est pas
seulement de ne pas oeuvrer à la
réduction des imans des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais aussi de
travailler actuellement à défaire ce qui
a été mise en place antérieurement
on le fait par exemple avec la
législation sur les émissions et la
consommation d'essence dans les flottes
de véhicules automobiles où on a tenté
de retirer le droit de la californie de
mettre en place une réglementation plus
stricte que celle au niveau fédéral donc
après avoir aboli la législation mise en
place par obama
on s'est attaqué ensuite au droit de
californie de mettre en place sa propre
législation et l'administration on voit
un cran plus loin
prétextant que la californie met en
place une stratégie à l'échelle
internationale
ça se disant que ce n'est que de
compétence fédérale
donc on tente de mettre fin en termes
juridiques à ce système des permis en
jambes c'est assez déplorable peut-être
mais en même temps est-ce qu un
fondement quand même réel de dire c'est
une compétence du gouvernement fédéral
un état américaine ne peut pas conclure
ce type d'entente avec d'autres
juridictions dans d'autres pays
vous avez dit exactement les mots clés
ce type d'entente donc à la fin ça va se
déterminer en termes juridiques mais
essentiellement ce qu'on a fait dans
cette stratégie québec californie c'est
d'abord dans chacun de ces états définir
ses propres stratégies en matière de
lutte aux changements climatiques se
fixer des cibles de réductions
spécifiques à chacun les états donc on
conserve ce cadre réglementaire ont
distribué au québec les droits
d'émissions aux entreprises selon des
règles qu'on s'est fixés au québec avec
un objectif l'avait bien dit en
introduction la deux
réduction du plafond total des émissions
le décret ministériel a fait passer ce
plafond de 65 millions de tonnes et en
2030 il ne sera que de 44 millions de
tonnes ces décisions des états mais
ensuite on a lié depuis le 1er janvier
ces deux marchés pour être beaucoup plus
efficaces en termes économiques se
partager l'ensemble des coûts de gestion
d'administration du système donc
permettre d'atteindre ces stratégies de
lutte aux changements climatiques au
coût le plus beau possible ou si vous
préférez pour une mangue dépenses
réussir en en faire plus en matière
environnementale donc cette liaison
internationale de ces deux marchés est
intéressante parce que ça réduit de
façon très spécifique les coûts
d'administration et ça permet aux
entreprises des deux états d'échangés
entre les droits d'émission j'ose
espérer que ce cadre légal va être
entérinée mais ce sens lorsqu'on
arrivera une décision à la fin dans
plusieurs années parce que là on est
peut-être dans une faille juridique là
c'est pas la première fois que le marché
du carbone québec californie est
contestée la dernière fois c'était en
2006 2007 c'était la structure de la
californie seulement où on contestait la
façon de l'avoir adoptée en ce disant
vous n'avez pas respecté les lois
californiennes visant à définir un
système de taxation et le jugement était
assez clair ces points système de
taxation plus proche d'un droit
administratif défini par chacun de ces
états avec un partage à l'échelle
internationale c'est intéressant parce
que c'est un système unique à l'échelle
planétaire en lice thème de permier
changeable européens se font dans un
système communautaire mais l'effet
d'avoir réussi à s'entendre entre deux
époques sont pas des états souverains à
mettre en place une structure
internationale c'est un gain je pense
intéressant pour le québec et ça permet
finalement d'avoir une très forte
complicité entre ces deux gestions ça
s'est fait de façon très complémentaires
intéressant ça permet donc de réduire la
facture totale est de générer des
revenus à travers la vente des droits
d'émission pour financer les stratégies
complémentaires de lutte aux changements
climatiques cela dit cette attaque de
l'administration trump qui vient de
façon presque direct touchées au québec
là est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
représente pour le québec pour le canada
est ce que ça pourrait ébranler
le cadre réglementaire canadien le
marché du carbone au québec
bah ça sera certainement parce que
l'idée c'est de mettre en place une
tarification du carbone eu lieu deux
stratégies un volet de taxation commune
a mis en place au palais fédéral ou un
système de plafonnement des émissions
moi je préfère le second système
notamment parce que justement on
plafonne ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et on facilite donc ces
transactions coût le plus bas possible
ça me semble plus efficace mais ça fait
pas consensus mais il ya deux théories
qui permettent de devrient efficacement
en termes d'outils économique c'est
paradoxal parce qu'il ya deux jours avec
les élections fédérales ont viennent de
lever cette incertitude sur la taxation
carbone
donc l'idée qu'au canada il y aura un
prix sur le carbone et prend la chose
réglée maintenant c'est une bonne idée
donc même si on conteste au niveau
américain cette légitimité de ce système
x ben ça sera citant axa et des impacts
sur la tarification du carbone dans le
rire dès qu'on aura un système que
québécois ou avec des partenaires à
l'échelle canadienne ne ferait pas
vraiment casse je pense que ça serait
moins efficace parce qu'il y aurait
effectivement moins d'entreprises donc
globalement ça nous obligerait à
dépenser plus pour atteindre nos
objectifs ce serait dommage mais pour
l'instant je pense que rien qui nous
amène à penser que ce système va être
champ auditif y ait de façon
significative avec ce type d' approche
qui va être très très longues et
peut-être que la solution va se faire en
termes politiques avec un gouvernement
moins climato sceptiques au niveau des
états unis on verra ce que la dimension
politique nous amène comme évolution ne
vous lancez pas de rentrer chez moi
j'essaie d'être optimiste de nature
webster merci beaucoup pour ses
explications ce soir ça fait un plaisir
en soirée